alright guys bang bang I've gotcha moth
here with me you need no introduction
but you've done everything from
incredible investing career to also
running the earth team face book built a
number of companies etc thanks for
coming to do this thanks for having me
on for sure let's let's start off with a
fun question I feel like nobody ever
gets asked this anymore but you're a
billionaire you I think actually made
like a billion and a half dollars last
year alone what was the moment that you
realized wow I have a billion dollar net
worth Wow well I mean it's kind of a
gross answer but it was a while ago
in my early thirties as it happened to
be but that was I mean pure luck like
it's not as if that that was sort of the
plan when I started it was just sort of
what the outcome was and the feeling was
pretty cool because I for a while all I
really wanted to do especially in my
teens in my 20s was be rich just because
it was the solution to being poor and
I'd spent the first 20 years being poor
and I didn't like it so it was a it was
a good feeling but to be honest with you
it also ended up being a little
destabilizing because and ultimately
better the destabilizing part was just
going through a process of realizing
that it didn't really solve any of my
problems and for a while it amplified
most of my insecurities and then it took
me a while to just become a more kind of
you know normal person and less of a
insecure person going through you know
their bouts of inferiority so it was it
was I guess now 10 years ago I'm 43 so I
guess about a decade ago it was great I
mean it was a it was a real notch in my
belt now what I'll tell you though is
it's been a crazy journey because the
last 10 years it's gone up way way up
then it's gone down you know I've been
I've had to rebuild eyes a couple times
it's been [ __ ] great I feel like when
you start
playing with big sums of money people
forget not only can you compound it
faster but you can also lose it faster
swings are really big and you know you
really have to this is why I kind of
like have really tried to migrate to a
much more patient model of doing my job
first I was trying to figure out what
should my job be and I don't think there
is a job that is an investor I actually
don't think that job exists I think that
you know if you're going to allocate
capital well over decades what you
really are better than anybody else is
just a good observer of the current
moment in time and it's taken me a long
time to sort of practice and refine a
toolkit which all comes back to my
psychology and so you know in
deconstructing myself over the last 10
years I've become a better person the
byproduct is I think I I make better
investing decisions because I'm less
prone to the wild swings that I went
through but in that process I've been
going through wild swings now I think
the swings that I go through I can
tolerate better because they're less
psychological and they're more the
result of bad structural decision-making
versus bad emotional decision-making so
that's been an interesting process for
sure and obviously there's a bunch of
chaos and kind of uncertainty in the
world today I listen to the recent
podcast a with Kara Swisher and if I got
this right you know billion and a half
or so last year that's what you guys
made you've got three public positions
1.7 yeah 1.7 okay you've got slack
Virgin Galactic and Amazon in the public
markets and then mostly sitting in cash
I'm assuming other than whatever
illiquid investments you've made you
know you keep talking about hey we're
only four weeks into kind of this
drawdown if you look historically that's
pretty earlier kind of the beginning of
the beginning I think it's a quote you
used what are some of the things that
you're paying attention to that you're
like when I see X that's when I'll start
to get excited and start getting a
little bit more aggressive and kind of
switched from an all cash mindset to
aggressiveness yeah so I think the setup
is important here so yeah last year we
were lucky we put about 1.7 billion on
the balance sheet I have been trimming
all this
here and so I'm not I'm not gonna be the
one here to tell you that I've been
trimming at the top I haven't been I've
been methodically selling more and more
every day I had four positions coming
into this year
Virgin Galactic Tesla Amazon and slack
in the public markets we have a large
portfolio of private equities I don't
really know where the market on that is
I tend to think it's probably down at
least thirty percent and ours is a
pretty good portfolio I would say and so
I think many companies could be down 60
or 70 if not completely out of business
so my mind sight has been to position
myself defensively build up a cash base
that we can very aggressively put to
work and so what signals am I looking at
well first is the signals that maybe
what we're doing is the right thing the
best way that I think about this is just
put yourself into the mindset of any
company right so pick a great company
that you know you've admired so I'll
pick one that I've admired for a very
long time for a good reason
workday simple example you know that's a
company that's basically like 10x their
market cap and you know the six or seven
years they've been public trading at an
incredible valuation cheap now in terms
of sort of like what they've done
historically but then I put myself into
and this is not to pick on workday but
it's a perfect example of of what other
companies will go through because I
think this is one of the best position
companies so they were before all of
these all of this craziness going to
companies the global 1000 and basically
saying listen like you need to upgrade
to big parts of your legacy
infrastructure right one part is about
how you do all of the human capital
planning and human resources management
of all the people that work for you the
second piece is how you actually count
all the money that you make your general
ledger right and so the first product
would compete against PeopleSoft the
second product competes against Oracle
financials okay now why am I telling you
this story because it's kind of like who
cares boring enterprise software well
now you put yourself into work day for a
second and ask yourself who are their
customers today April 1st 2020
well whatever segments of their revenue
came from oil and gas just went to zero
right oil is at 18 19 bucks a barrel
there are a lot of very smart people
that are telling you now that oil
probably gets to 15 if not $10 a barrel
some could go to 0 you've had the tar
sands effectively trade to 0 in Canada
you've had your first bankruptcy filing
this morning when we woke up which was a
multi-billion dollar company in the
Bakken Shale in North Dakota so if
you're an oil and gas company you're no
longer thinking about your general
ledger because you have no revenue and
you're no longer thinking about
upgrading your it you know HR software
because you may not have any employees
right so that whole segment stops by if
you're an airline company or a
transportation and logistics company
that whole segment has stopped by if
you're a hospitality business that whole
segment has stopped buying if you're in
the banking sector that whole segment
has stopped buying now the spectrum of
decisions are different on the one end
these companies are bankrupt at the
closest end in banking your market cap
has been shaved by 30 to 40 percent
which means that you have to now start
and figure out how you save from an
effects perspective a lot of money to
basically try to get profitability in
line so that you can grow out of this
thing and so decisions that you could
otherwise live without you stop and
decisions that you could otherwise stall
you stall now this is for one of the
best run companies in the world so then
if you take that trace route that we
just did and traceroute a bunch of other
companies random companies pick a retail
business let's take a retail business
Macy's okay well what was Macy's
spending money on while they were
spending money on people they just
furloughed 200,000 they spent money on
physical plant they're gonna stop paying
their rent they spent money on
point-of-sale saw
where that's gonna go to zero they spent
money on merchandise that's going to
stop and now you look at their customers
well the customers the point-of-sale
manufacturers right let's look at those
companies as an example I think there's
about 15 billion dollars of public
market cap and folks that sell POS POS
is used to stand for point-of-sale it
may now stand for piece of [ __ ] the
entire category has gone to zero the
entire category 15 billion dollars of
market cap has been eviscerated nobody's
bonding point of sale software or
hardware or terminals right if you think
about all the effects that those
companies spent five six billion a year
in running their businesses
they've stopped so my point is that when
you start to follow the trail of
breadcrumbs for any company in any
sector what I am slowly realizing is
that we're a very interconnected web of
businesses and that as much as you
thought you were insulated from what's
happening I tend to think that what is
going on is not a sector based drawdown
in leisure Hospitality banking and a
couple of others but this is a there are
implications for every single business
so why that's important is for a company
to reset I think you're gonna start to
hear the term zero-based budget a lot so
what is zero based budgeting zero based
budgeting means you start with a clean
sheet of paper and you say well this
company is worth nothing I have no
revenue let me build it back up bottoms
up line by line excruciatingly ly line
by line and when you do that you'll
understand what you're willing to bear
in your expense basis right so I tend to
think in that process that takes six or
nine months to unfold people will not be
in a position to buy things that were
nice to haves people will not be in a
position to actually even spend on
must-haves so if you think about like
you know if you're an energy business
and you're thinking about you know look
at even Buffett's businesses I mean the
craziest thing about Buffett's letter
this year was how
capital-intensive and unproductive his
energy businesses were their negative
roee well in a world where you know you
have energy consumption falling I think
the average power consumption has fallen
by about 15 percent for the regional
utilities you know but you're forced to
price within a band and you're also
forced to do certain capital upgrades
especially in the you know in the case
of what just happened in California
where you could get sued because you
have faulty equipment you start a fire
blah blah blah every single company is
going to be under an enormous amount of
pressure to rebase line their expenses
and in these next six to nine months
they're gonna figure out what they're
willing to spend and then they're going
to start spending cautiously I think so
I tend to think this is a multi-year and
I don't want to become too alarmist but
I do think it's it's something that is
sort of akin to a depression like this
is 15 to 25 percent unemployment and
it's gonna take a long time for us to
sort through all the damage you know you
bring up a really good point
I saw a stat yesterday that the US
domestic box office so kind of just
movie theaters in general this time last
year on the week March 22 26 they made
200 million dollars last week they made
$5,100
I mean literally many nine percent
although just a decimation now that
Emilia brings the idea of like hey are
you gonna see an industry basically
evaporate right well people ever go back
to the movies with the buyers to etc and
a buddy of mine said to me well that's
the movies and that's kind of a nice to
have right people have Netflix or other
ways they could get some of that content
because what about all the startups that
were built that just service other
startups right that was the rage for a
number of years and so it sounds like
you're making the argument like this
isn't just hospitality or movie theaters
this could be kind of across industries
depending where you are and what your
balance sheet looks like you could be
disappearances you're bringing up some
really good examples so let's follow
those examples so let's trace throughout
those right this is a key word
traceroute [ __ ] follow the trail of
breadcrumbs we had
this is now the time we're honestly like
the the propensity to action should be
avoided at all costs like this is where
you sit down you tape your hands to your
hips your lap you don't touch the
[ __ ] keyboard and you just learn and
you study you know you're not supposed
to be day trading in moments like this
you're supposed to be learning but let's
take your examples so you know the the
the major movie compass to do x' were
forced essentially to go day and date
now the problem with that is that you
can't put that genie back in the bottle
and the other problem with it is that
they may have gotten the pricing wrong
they have no time they had no time to
really do a pricing elasticity and
release these movies for $100 a ticket
on itunes they've released them for $20
and so it's going to be very difficult
for Disney and you know Universal and
Warner Brothers and Sony Pictures so all
of a sudden come back and say hey we're
gonna try to give them movie theaters
back their window of exclusivity I think
that's that that's basically very
difficult if not impossible and then the
second thing that's going to happen is
that they're not gonna have the same
pricing power that they would have had
with the online distributors now all of
that has one really important
implication which is the cost of the
movies that they make are going to
change and then as a result the cost of
what they're willing to pay is going to
change as a result the cost of what they
pay they're unionized employees is gonna
change what the CGI maker you know
charges changes what the caterer charges
changes and so this is why in when you
have these big sort of cataclysmic
economic events what you have is a
period that's very deflationary right
you have a period where prices fall and
fall and fall now in the Great
Depression the only way that we could
buck that trend is to basically get rid
of the gold standard you know in 33 I
think it was and so we're gonna have to
have some version of that which is to
basically create a bottom on pricing and
to create a bottom on price stability so
the movie theaters more than likely go
BK and in that if you were a read or if
you were a tenant or if you own the land
you're gonna have to figure out how to
repurpose that how to try to pay your
debt obligations otherwise you're gonna
go back
corruptor you're gonna go default or
you're just gonna hand the keys over to
those facilities to banks at which point
you know probably the beneficiary is
amazon or some other sort of like
physical retail that needs last-mile
distribution and some of these movie
theaters represent the right size and
the right physical location okay so
that's that's one then you talked about
startups that's another great example
you know for a long time
I think in 2015 or 16 I started to
become very bearish on enterprise
software and the reason was because we
shifted much more towards SMB than we
did towards mid market and enterprise
and the reason was because the money
cycle was faster it was you could put
small amounts of dollars to work the
companies would sell online via credit
card to other SMBs who would buy very
quickly you would show revenue traction
and then you were able to use that to
then go and raise an upper out so
venture capitalists loved it the
entrepreneurs loved it they used it to
attract employees because the equity
looked like they was accreting very
quickly but then you realize how brittle
your customer base is in a moment like
this because they are the first to stop
paying they are the first to not honor
their contracts they're the first to go
out of business unfortunately because
they don't have the cash cushion and so
there's going to be unfortunately a lot
of carnage in the SMB space that there
won't be in the enterprise space so now
go back to a company like word day or
you know ServiceNow or sa P or some
young startups that have explicitly
chosen to sell into the global 1000
netskope is one as an example that sells
security software into the global 1000
they consumed enormous amounts of
capital to build their go to market but
in many ways that capital becomes a
protective moat that will keep them safe
in a moment like this because their
customers have a higher probability of
staying in business now their business
may slow down their business may get
rear ated but their business isn't going
out of business but if you were selling
mostly to
Andie's there's a very good chance that
50% of your revenue is impaired and at
that point again if you're already money
losing which most of these startups were
selling to SMBs at price points that
didn't make sense because you were
trying to get out of a J curve it's
going to be next to impossible the other
strategy that startups also employed was
being mono product right it was not only
go to SMB charge something small if
anything at all but do it for one single
point solution create a wedge and then
expand well again you go back to this
problem that when companies are
rebuilding their expense base what
they're doing is making decisions about
what costs to bear the company that has
a mono product solution is last in line
to be considered because it doesn't
solve enough of the CEO CFO CIOs
problems so then all of a sudden you
start to make substandard decisions
meaning you'll take Microsoft because
it's a whole stack of things it's one
person it's one sale
they can now discount and you have this
increasing returns of scale property
that that benefits Microsoft
disproportionately right so you have to
be very unique you have to be a zoom or
a slack or octa in that environment to
be able to defend yourself adequately so
that's also a very problematic dynamic
amano product company is going to be
very challenged a SMB focus go to market
sales strategy is very challenged so to
your point like the the examples of of
contraction I think are numerous the
examples of green shoots exist but
they're harder to find and to be quite
honest they're speculative because
they're they're not about adoption
they're now more about valuation like
everybody loves zoom everybody loves
slack it's it's fabulous you have to be
able to right-size valuation in moments
like this as well yeah one of the things
that I keep saying to people is a lot of
companies thought about are we recession
proof nobody had ever thought are we
pandemic proof right and the easiest
example is take like a barber in New
York City they would say all day long oh
I can last a recession everyone needs a
hair
cut now all of a sudden literally the
government has mandated go home right
and revenue goes to zero and can they
pay there right etc and you kind of
again do that that Tracy
back and you saw like tump it's a big
real estate guy who's got a bunch of
hospitality real estate and he came out
pretty early and said look I need help
because I can't give the rate of bateman
to the things that you want me to do for
these companies because I got people
that I don't money to and you kind of go
through this sore cap you know the
circle of of that flow of cash and you
realize like almost every industry is
now turning to the government and saying
hey I need a bailout right mean
literally the movie theater the reason
why that data came out is cuz they're
asking for a bailout right this is and
this is where the rubber meets the road
because you know right now before all of
this happened the government was already
a third of GDP and you know we are we
are now after all of this is going to be
said and done because I think the odds
if we're gonna be sort of in the 8 to 10
trillion dollar range is probably very
high which essentially means that you
know this year at a minimum 55 to 60
percent of GDP is going to be government
sponsored but for the foreseeable future
we're going to basically be very reliant
on the government the federal government
and then you know there there's there's
another impeding sort of cataclysmic
wave that we have to deal with which is
not just all these companies but all the
states and all the municipalities and
counties and cities that are just going
to be completely upside down on debt but
they have dramatically less flexibility
than the federal federal bureaucracy
does in basically obviously just
printing money so we have a very
difficult moment here where what we have
realized is that in the search for
efficiency we have abandoned resiliency
and we have to pivot our economy to
resilience there was an article today
that the Chinese government was
basically metering out PPE equipment so
masks gowns gloves etc evenly and why I
think that's interesting was I think it
was interesting that you know there was
a moment where the president about two
weeks ago started to back down from
naming coronavirus the China virus or
the Chinese virus at some point I think
that there was a political gambit inside
the government that said we should try
to label this as a foreign scourge and I
suspect that what probably happened not
to be conspiratorial or anything is that
you know
needed a lot of things from China and
China said listen not only do you need
to back down and never say this again
you need to apologize to all the Asian
Americans in the United States and by
the way he did it and he's never said it
since but since then the Chinese
government is still not flowing PBE into
the United States at the same velocity
as they should
relative to other countries so it goes
to show you that you know in our in our
sort of this hell-bent desire for
efficiency we've empowered certain
countries and economies to have
incredible leverage over us these
fulcrum you know it's it's kind of like
you know when you look at the dead stack
of a company you look at the fulcrum
asset right you look at the fulcrum
security that's what that what we call
the pivot security the thing around
which everything crumbles and it turns
out that our Achilles heel are simple
trading goods from countries like China
that they can hold back from us this is
just incredible
and so we have to pivot to a much more
resilient economic model and in that by
the way that's I think how we countered
the deflationary pressure of you know
the 1930s because inherently what it
allows you to do is actually see a world
of rising wages and rising prices if we
sort of insource more of the production
or at least the last mile completion of
the things that America needs to run its
economy yeah it's all idea that the
supply chain is a national security
concern right and I think that as we see
this deflationary environment now you
know the average American has no clue
you know kind of the balance between as
asset prices go down the dollar
strengthening and obviously the feds can
have to step in they're gonna have to do
the quantitative easing expand the
balance sheet where do we go with that
right and obviously I know that you're a
big kind of schmuck insurance as Bitcoin
proponent but is this a thing we're
seeing you know the Fed balance sheet
the latest chart I saw was literally
it's just a vertical line right B
they're adding hundreds of billions of
dollars I mean it literally just looks
like it just shot straight up in the air
and part of this goes let's say we go to
8 10 trillion dollars on the Fed balance
sheet what is the fear around higher
levels of inflation will that even be
enough to get
the deflationary environment like where
does this take us because I think that
the writing's on the wall but we have to
go there but I guess like what's the
second and third order effect of going
in that direction if if it's the status
quo I think that we already have the
example which is Japan which is like
look you know the crazy thing is like
you know in 1971 when we formally
abandoned the gold standard the reality
was every country realized that all of a
sudden they had infinite power and it
lied in in each of their central banks
and the ability for those central banks
to print fiat money and so ever since
then we've just basically been printing
ad nauseam effectively and what Japan is
really shown over the last twenty years
is if as long as I keep buying my own
debt everything's going to be ok because
you know I know I'm paying myself back
and so I'm just round-tripping money
constantly I can keep this whole thing
afloat for a very long time so the the
idea that the the typical rules of you
know debt-to-gdp matter they kind of
matter but they don't now America has a
different problem in that it has always
been the reserve currency and there's a
lot of foreign entities governments and
otherwise that own American debt which
is a little bit less typical than in
Japan it's true that other people on the
Japanese that but overwhelmingly the
Japanese government so you know the
United States can go and play this game
for a while but eventually it comes home
to roost because you're going to have to
start issuing paper at a higher and
higher risk premium the question is how
do you do it and this is where things
become very complicated and so unless
you find a way to break this
deflationary cycle so one can be an
explicit decision to just refactor your
economy and that and I would advocate
for that which is you know we decide
that you know the way to sort of create
inflation meaning how do you grow your
way out of this so not how you issue
debt to drive GDP higher but how you
actually grow your way out of this is by
putting enough money in the system to
actually create incentives
to do things differently but actually
cause prices to go up and I think the
only way to do that is to economically
incentivize and essentially mandate
things to be much more domestically
created and produced because it gets us
closer to full employment and it allows
people to be more competitive in the job
market and it forces companies to pay
employees more it forces companies to
then charge more for their products and
we break the back of these deflationary
cycle because we were already on it
after 2008 with QE I think we're gonna
go faster and faster towards this wall
and the only way you can slow down and
veer away from this wall and I'll tell
you what the wall was in a second is by
basically forcing some kind of inflation
in the absence of that the wall is
debasement it's basically just saying
okay it's not worth as much anymore
sorry and you know I mean to be very
honest and I and I can I I don't I don't
mean to say this as as flippantly as
it's gonna come off but that's what
third-world countries do
it's a dictator playbook get all the
assets and just print money and it's not
but it's not what the American economy
should do it's not what America should
do and it's not what the reserve
currency of the world can really afford
to do so I think the only solution is
path one and it's gonna require us to
really look at competition corruption
regulatory capture economic incentives
in a very different way we're gonna need
a new deal we're gonna need a massive
stimulus package that incentivizes
building things creating things
repatriating supply chain back to the
United States and in that I think
there's a way out of this you know it's
interesting because what it then leads
to is there's a lot of quantitative
easing that goes on and to avoid that
debasement I think that you're you know
directionally correct right now the
strategy has been let's buy every credit
product we possibly can stuff into the
our mandate
right they're doing everything from
Treasuries mortgage-backed securities
corporate credit all the way don't want
it then leads to like well what else can
we buy and obviously equities is kind of
this like religious topic that once you
step across that line I think there's a
lot of people that start yelling and
screaming how do you just like evaluate
should they do it should they not would
it be helpful and kind of navigate that
conversation I don't I don't think it's
additive to be quite honest with you I
think the debt markets are much much
more important to the functioning of an
economic system than equities are I
think equities are much more of an
individual company's game whereas the
debt marks or the debt markets are much
more intertwined and interconnected and
they all live in a very complicated
ecosystem meaning you know carnivals
convert doesn't affect Facebook their
fees are just like not correlated things
they don't they don't really touch each
other really but you know triple B
corporate credit versus triple a
corporate credit live in a very
interconnected stack ultimately and
those live in a stack that are related
to Munez and related to mortgage-backed
securities and and related to the CDs
that you layer on top of baskets of all
of these things it's it's much more
complicated important market for how
capital markets and economies run debt
that are that is I think that before you
know the Federal Reserve's starts to try
to sort of cherry-pick equities which
they're not going to I mean at the most
they buy ETF's but they buy the index
but I think you probably have a much
bigger problem which is what do you do
about pensions and I think before you
start speculating in equities I think
there's probably a massive bailout of a
bunch of these pensions that have to
happen and I think that there would be
more political support for that before
there was political support for buying
equities yeah I mean the pension issue
is so bad in some areas right just I
mean just literally when you look at the
numbers you're like it's impossible to
get back to where they need to get I
don't care if they've got the best you
know investors in the world running
these things is the solution only a
bailout right or or let it fail I mean
is that basically it's a binary let it
fail or bail them out mm well you have
to be able to mouth
the bailout isn't going to be to
corporates I think the bailout is going
to happen at the city county and state
level and here's the problem is that you
can't politicize that meaning you can't
bail out you know the Houston Fire
Department pension because the city of
Houston issued these bonds or you know
the you know state of Texas issued some
general obligation bonds and some of it
went to Houston but then not do it for
California because ones Republican ones
Democrat I don't think that dog hunts so
this is a very complicated thing that
once you start to do it you have to do
it for everybody and this is where again
I go back to like before you go there
you have to realize that that is a
never-ending spiral and you have to try
everything else before you do that but
the unfunded pension obligations that
that sit in companies are important but
at the end of the day you know that is
also a function of haphazard management
in part what's much more critical are
the pensions of states and cities and
municipalities because these are the
critical workers that we rely on these
are the people on the frontlines easier
policemen your firefighters you know
these are the people that are working
public utilities your teachers and it's
it's it's wholly unfair that those folks
basically get you know [ __ ] over I
just saw a report yesterday the MTA in
New York City is saying that Subway
ridership is down 90% and obviously
revenue basically disappears and now
they're worried about being able to
service some of the bonds etcetera that
they've issued and so they're turning to
the government and saying hey we need a
bailout - right and you just get in this
world of everyone needs help and I agree
with you it's gonna be hard to
cherry-pick well we'll help you and we
won't help you because now you're
playing kingmaker well hi but okay I
think I think it's it's even it's even
harder than that how do you know who to
help meaning okay you can get away with
it like let's just say you actually try
to be a kingmaker so you know the
stimulus bill
slowed-down for a few days because there
was a fear from the Democrats that you
know minuchin wanted essentially of half
a trillion dollar slush fund well let's
just take the extreme and say that he
had gotten it he's only going to do one
or two deals that don't work before
everybody says hey you need to stop and
it's only half a trillion dollars in a
twenty two trillion dollar economy so at
the end of the day it still doesn't do
anything and if you if you take the 22
trillion of GDP and layer on all the
pensions and layer on all these other
things it's a drop in the bucket I mean
like we need to come up with 50 60
trillion dollars when it's all said and
done so even if he had done it and even
if he had done it poorly what we would
realize as cherry-picking doesn't work
it's an all-or-none problem this is why
I think again we have to go back to we
have to spend our way and try to inflate
our way out of it and basically what we
have to do is choose the path of
inefficiency because inefficiency
creates costs and then costs are passed
downstream and then you know you have to
get to full employment so that people
can you know switch jobs more easier for
higher wages that is the only way we can
get out of this yeah this leads to
Bitcoin right you're famous for calling
it the schmuck insurance I'm not going
to say that we're in the situation where
the insurance is needed yet but we're
definitely headed that direction over a
long period of time
how are your views on Bitcoin kind of
changed over time and have you bought
more Bitcoin sold Bitcoin or change
anything and kind of a portfolio
allocation standpoint so first of all I
think you said it exactly right which is
that I think that this is the set up
meaning I think Bitcoin needed a moment
like this for it to be relevant in 2003
oh sorry 2013 I bought a lot and at one
point I think I had almost 5% of all the
bitcoins my basis is about 80 bucks a
coin I've never bought more most of my
Bitcoin now sit with a company and you
know they use it for trading purposes
they use it to run a bunch of other
strategies and
I did that mostly for safety and
security and peace of mind I didn't want
to deal with it I wanted to own equity
in the business that equity can be
hedged that equity can be tax structured
and advantageous Lee and then it allows
them to run a big business which
generates cash and I can get a cash and
you know dividend stream so I have not
bought since I initially basically wrote
that article for Bloomberg in 2013 my
thoughts are the following right now I
think what you're seeing is that it's
still a speculative instrument and it's
too speculative for it to be reliable so
if you're going to make the case that
you know it should replace fiat currency
well one thing you have to look at is
the volatility of the US dollar and you
can't replace it with something that's 9
sigma more volatile it doesn't work and
the reason it doesn't work is that it's
- again going back to what markets are
important the only market that's even
more important than the debt markets are
the currency markets and what you see is
enormous amounts of liquidity where 5%
moves so 500 basis points are newsworthy
well those 500 basis points in the
absence of some massive exhaustion is
that that take years to play out and in
that there's value because it allows
more market participants to be active in
that market so that they can use it as a
critical pillar of how they run their
business but now all of a sudden if you
have 2,000 basis point moves 1/2 hour
you can't effectively use it and so what
it does is it pushes it into this ghetto
of day traders and speculators and right
now that's where we are we're in that
ghetto and you need to get out and the
way that it gets out is that you need to
flush the speculators and day traders
out and you need to have still some
basis of interest from long-term holders
and then you need to have it slowly look
like the traditional infrastructure
could really implode so again I go back
to we
our driving slowly but we are driving
towards a top of a cliff and then we're
going to drive much much faster down
that cliff tore down that hill and at
the end of it is a is a huge brick wall
the way we avoid it is by pivoting to a
resilient economy where we introduced in
efficiency and cost and inflate our way
out of it or debasement
the path dependence for Bitcoin is if it
looks like path two is likely it will
really emerge as a flight to safety and
over the next ten years where this
trajectory is going to take shape and it
is a ten-year trajectory you'll have a
lot of time to vector into it to protect
yourself and to hedge yourself and I've
always thought of Bitcoin as a very
binary investment whether it goes from
eighty to eight thousand to six thousand
to three thousand to thirteen thousand
it just it doesn't matter this is either
zero or it's Millions
because what it will do is it will
create a quasi gold standard it'll
create an index except instead of having
to own gold where gold is owned by
central banks it is an instrument that
has value that's determined by in
between its participants and it's owned
by everybody
so maybe the correct way to say this is
that it's not gold but in gold being
gold 2.0 which some people have used
about Bitcoin what it does is it
replaces the the method of value
transfer that you need for fiat money to
be valuable but that only happens if the
US dollar looks like it's going to
careen into this wall so I think that's
the bet so the setup is here so before
there was no path dependence meaning you
were speculating and not really hoping
because you know if you were if you're
using as schmuck insurance as I was you
were kind of hoping it would never come
in but now if the probability you know
was 1% that that it would be valuable
unfortunately the probability is now
probably like 5 or 10%
and there's a real chance by 2030 we
don't find a way to inflate our way out
of this and that the only way to break
the back of deflation is essentially to
create some quasi form of gold standard
but it'll be almost impossible to do
that between governments and central
banks they'll never agree on an
instrument and they'll never agree on an
exchange but then bottoms up people
could decide to do it yeah and the
minute that that happens individuals and
people then it's a done deal I broke
some glass a couple of weeks ago I
basically said look there's a lot of
people going on television and saying I
think X is happening or you know for Y
reasons and stuff and I said but the one
thing I haven't heard anyone make the
argument for is if you zoom out to the
big picture are we actually seeing the
failure of the fiat currency experiment
now it's not gonna happen tomorrow it's
over a long period of time but once you
got off that gold standard it introduced
some advantages but it also introduced
some disadvantages and there's this guy
in San Francisco Brent Johnson at a
santiago capital that I interviewed he's
got this theory calls it the dollar
milkshake Theory which is all these
central banks are introducing liquidity
into the world and the u.s. actually has
the straw so they get a suck all of the
value into the dollar right so
everyone's introducing liquidity u.s.
sucks it in dollar gets stronger asset
prices go down you get the bleeding what
happens if all of a sudden Bitcoin and
the currency it you're moving into is
not so much the most stable but it's
actually an access play right if you're
in certain areas of the world
I want dollars I just can't get the
dollars right the next best thing is is
to access so I think that that I think
that that will also happen that the
thing is though and I can say this
because I I was born in a developing
third-world country those countries
don't matter for [ __ ] so look the
reality is we're gonna have a lot of
failures meaning the the the good news
is the United States is incredibly
important
it's the fulcrum security of the world
so we're not gonna fail out there
there's going to be a lot of pain so for
example the eurozone is gonna get
stretched right to the breaking point
they're not gonna break but it's gonna
get stretched right to the breaking
point so they'll be okay but then when
you look at emerging markets it's very
complicated I mean so could you see
Argentina fail again
yes in fact they probably will if this
if the southern hemisphere sees a
massive outbreak of koruna virus as they
go into the fall in wintertime and
they're ill-equipped to deal with it
which the odds are reasonable could
Brazil fail yeah possible could they
devalue again probable Central and South
American countries yes Asian countries
yes so in all of those markets you'll
probably have a bid by the most astute
people in those markets to basically
defend their defend what they own
because who wants to own you know pesos
or bought or I mean you still want to do
that grey eyes it doesn't make any sense
and the risk for all of those currencies
and those markets is quite negative
quite quite quite negative
so there'll probably be a bid there it's
just insufficient again I go back to we
have to remember the gross tonnage
matters here and there you know the
[ __ ] fruit peddler you know in Sri
Lanka just he doesn't matter and there's
just no amount if there's not enough
fruit peddlers in the world to overcome
central banks so I just think that there
will always be a bid for those folks I
think it'll go up on the margins because
he's there will be a lot of I think
emerging market failures first of the
developed world but I don't think beyond
that there's going to be some massive
bid and that's the tipping point yeah
it's a fair agreement I was sore skiers
real quick a couple of years ago maybe
two years ago now you made a pretty big
I think strategic move in the way that
you started to allocate capital and the
way that I read it was you wanted to
make much more concentrated bets where
you hit higher conviction and a lot of
managing outside capital and things like
that kind of prevented that when you
look at your portfolio today you
basically have three public securities
that make up you know almost on a
percent I found a hundred percent of
your portfolio got a cash illiquid stuff
kind of looking back good decision happy
with it would you do it again and kind
of where do you look at now from just
portfolio construction and concentration
risk that you take like how are you
thinking about it kind of two or three
years into this
it was it was a great decision I think
the the way that it happened was too
haphazard I think that if I had had the
courage to believe in myself I would
have probably instead of let it happen
in you know four or five kind of cuts I
would have just done it all on one day
and walked in and said here's what's
happening here's everybody's severance
packages here's what you guys could make
and you know I wish you the best signed
this and let's be done and shake hands I
didn't really have the courage because
it was a process where I was evolving to
this place over a year and so I kind of
trickled my way into into the decision
do I regret the outcome no I kind of
regret the process I wish that that was
better but you know my setup right now
is like I think to myself okay there are
there are two big aspects of my life and
they're they're measurable in very
different ways so in my personal life my
whole job is to realize kind of two
things the first is and this and the
coronavirus has been amazing for me
which is I'm powerless I'm just as
powerless as the fruit vendor and just
as powerless as the President of the
United States we are all equal in a
moment like this and that is incredibly
humbling to internalize okay we're all
equal but it doesn't mean that we're
irrelevant so being powerless is one
thing but we are very relevant
I am relevant to my friends and my
family and I have a responsibility to be
really functional for them in moments
like this so it's about maintaining
clarity making sure I realize how lucky
I am being appreciative staying healthy
helping my family talking to my friends
making sure that when I see them in
moments were there you know when you're
cooped up for a month it's tough it's
helping them so so I've realized that
measuring myself in my personal life is
about those things how to stay relevant
but yet realize that I am powerless how
do I be functional and measure my
measure
my ability to be functional so I have
like a little you know stick it pad and
I write my friends names on there and I
cycle through it and I make calls you
know I have books that I try to read
passages that I try to just stay focused
and then you know what it's time to be
with my family really be present with
them that's how I measure in my
professional life I have always wanted
to be the best at something I just
didn't know what that was and I wanted
to push myself to try to be the best and
right now I'm in a lucky position where
you know this is the moment I think for
me where I can take you know a three
four billion dollar balance sheet and
ten exit and so how do I do it and in
doing so it's not the money
it's proving how good I could be in
these moments where I need to be clear
minded where I need to make really good
decisions where I need to manage my
psychology I'll give you an example like
as I told you like I've been trimming
where markets were down ten thousand or
thousand where markets were up a
thousand where you know and and I see
all these folks who would be like oh I
you know clip the top and I you know
covered my shorts at the bottom and I
think wow I'm an idiot I mean I didn't
do any of those things I've just been
dollar cost averaging my way to more
liquidity and it would make me feel
insecure but I had to battle through
that and put myself in a position now
where I have an even bigger cash pile
and I can say okay I can make a couple
billion dollar bets here and try to 10x
it and in doing so I can be part of the
solution I could hire lots of people I
could you know solve really important
problems that I've always wanted to
solve and I'm putting myself to that
challenge and so I don't regret any of
it but I'm really cognizant of this line
because if I am dysfunctional at home I
will not be functional at work and if I
fail at work I need to firewall my
personal life so that I can still be
functional because it's it's this is a
moment
I've really I'm trying to learn how to
have equanimity and I think like if you
look at the best people in work at any
work they have an equanimity to it they
they are humble enough to realize
they're a participant that they're not
some all-seeing all-powerful omnipotent
presence they wait for their moment and
then they participate in a functional
way and that's a real skill I think very
few people have it Buffett has it very
few people have it
speaking of Buffett you and him are in
somewhat similar situation and I think a
little bit different size and and that
you have cash on the sidelines you're
being patient you kind of understand at
least generally where we are on this
cycle and and having that patience will
likely pay off when you go to get
aggressive I think a lot of people are
saying you know when's Omaha gonna move
type thing for you where are you going
to look is it public market is it
looking at kind of more the hard text I
think you've been talking in the private
markets is it may be something that we
aren't expecting like real estate or
other assets kind of how do you think
about okay I've got a couple billion
dollars how do i 10x it there's a lot of
risk involved in that obviously right so
how do you kind of think through that
the way that I'm asking the question
right now is first and foremost what is
not going to change and you know there's
a bunch of things that are not going to
change meaning you're still going to go
out eventually you're still going to
travel eventually you're still going to
buy things offline eventually you'll
still you know want to make things that
will require energy eventually you'll
still need to eat you'll still need to
clothe yourself you'll still need access
to the Internet
all what this moment is good at doing is
clarifying a hierarchy of needs and so
the first thing that we're doing and
this is for us and my team and I a
multi-week process is just re
underwriting what are our basic needs
and that's what I'm doing right now and
I'm trying to ask myself just really
simple kind of basic questions where I
look at my kids and if I tell them here
are the things that will never change
they'll be like yeah it makes sense from
there and we've done this because we're
a little bit further ahead in some of
those sectors that we identified early
they're not super complicated but then
what we've said is which companies have
now been disproportionately punished
despite basic needs that should remain
relatively and violent over the long arc
of time so I'll give you an example you
know the one of the things that this is
strained is the internet itself and
within that I think one thing that we
have realized is how misconfigured
telecom infrastructure wireless
infrastructure and the wireless
providers functionally are so let's
think about this they have physical
wireline infrastructure they have a you
know very complicated very expensive
wireless infrastructure that doesn't
really support massive massive
throughput they have incredibly
complicated very expensive back-office
effects to run it because they were
traditional wireline carriers that try
to morph they spend hundreds of hundreds
of millions of dollars trying to build
capacity both in terms of spectrum as
well as satellites and then to top all
of that [ __ ] Sunday off the cherry on
top is that they have a physical retail
infrastructure that is the only way for
you to interact if you want to switch
your plan if you want to upgrade your
plan if you want to switch carriers you
know they've been they've been resistant
to e sims now you're sitting at home and
even if you wanted to switch every
carrier is thinking to themselves
I can't run ads I can't switch because I
can't deliver a sim to these people
because the stores are closed now take
out all that dysfunction the wireless
carriers will continue to be more and
more important you know we've we've
realized that we need to have a more
resilient intranet we've realized that
it need
to be somewhat more homegrown as well we
can't you know we can't rely on hallway
or Ericsson necessarily we have to have
you know internal American products and
solutions we need to service the rural
areas of the country as well as the you
know cities cities have very different
complicated patterns of density and
servicing that are not done well I mean
like you go to a place like New York
City and Verizon is just complete [ __ ]
so we know that the outcome is but we
don't know what's the path to get there
is and we have a bunch of companies that
have just gotten decimated now then if
you take that and you overlay those
dynamics in emerging markets what you
see already is a bunch of bankruptcies
so that's an example of where we've said
okay do we step in
is there a company here that we can buy
out of you know the Chilean equivalent
of chapter 11 bankruptcy here you know
chapter 7 bankruptcy and what would that
look like or you know are there are
there companies that we could get a hold
of but buying the debt and then
basically trans transforming it that's
an example we've been monitoring very
closely all sources of alternative data
so what's an example of alternative data
OpenTable has some incredible data Yelp
has incredible data second measure
credit card panels there's a company I
can't remember the name who we use for
footfall data TomTom and we use that to
build a complexion and what we're asking
ourselves is what does this show in
terms of patterns another thing that
we've looked at as a result of that is
in commercial real estate so I think
that commercial real estate is
fundamentally impaired now because when
you factor in just like you and I are as
productive as if you and I by the way
just think about this you had flown to
San Francisco we could not connect you
flew back but you stayed in a hotel you
had some meals blah blah blah let's say
roughly you spent three or four thousand
dollars on that business trip you and I
are creating just as much value it cost
us zero
yep so the point for you to spend five
thousand dollars of effects to generate
this asset is going to be incrementally
harder for you to justify
it's going to be more to pleasure and
waste than it is out of need when you
factor that into how it will flow into
commercial real estate commercial real
estate is fundamentally impaired it's
it's essentially what Tom Baraka said
but in a world where that commercial
real estate is impaired that's not going
to be completely true now there are
certain REITs for example that only
serve as big-box retailers specifically
Walmart Amazon distribution and
groceries now faves on they've seen 50%
draw downs as well because you know you
throw the baby out with the bathwater
when things like this happen and so
we've been going bottoms up in certain
REITs literally looking at property by
property trying to figure out are these
things valued fairly or reasonably the
thing with this work that I'll tell you
is that it is incredibly humbling
because it is unbelievably boring and
super [ __ ] tactical I mean you got to
be a worker in moments like this a
humble worker put your hat on you know
and just grind it out and it is
excruciating ly boring numbing
time-consuming but in it is where you'll
find I think the Nuggets but that's what
we're doing we're prioritizing needs
we're asking ourselves what won't change
and then we're looking at things and
essentially what that leads us to is a
bunch of offline businesses or hybrid
businesses the other part of our
exercise is saying what things need to
change and all of that leads us to our
portfolio private businesses and what we
are doing there as we put out feelers
and what we've said to people is like
look we have buying capacity here we're
willing to be the buyer but we want
control and so you know I'm not
interested in putting in 15 million
dollars in a Series C or a series d
extension round but I'll buy your
business for 50 million a hundred
million two hundred million and then
I'll fund the rest of the J curve to get
out of it if we think that that solution
is interesting and so we're looking in
healthcare we're looking at climate
change we're looking at education
those are the three areas that we think
are going to change the fastest in this
move to resiliency so that's kind of
what we're doing but honestly dude it's
not glamorous it's super [ __ ]
tactical well it brings up two things
right the first is I don't know who said
it but basically the return you get is
the price you buy that right and that's
the work that you're doing now is trying
to figure out you know what are those
undervalued assets that if you buy it at
the right price today it basically locks
in a significant return over time the
other thing that you've done is you use
the SPAC and obviously the big one is
Virgin Galactic what's kind of the
thoughts there would you ever put social
capital into a speck structure are there
other things that you're kind of
thinking through seeing the success of
the version I think what virgin showed
us is that there's a lot of incredible
tech companies that should be public and
that when you're doing something
ambitious there's a huge appetite by
retail investors as well as hedge funds
and pension funds and other things to
have direct exposure to alpha it is a
fundamentally uncorrelated business -
anything else of its kind and in that
you know the the anti-correlation the
lack of correlation is an incredible
good thing to have when you're
constructing a portfolio and this is why
you know who knows what it'll do over
the next year or two but it's still up
40 percent I mean that's just incredible
how could you say that in a market
that's down 20 odd percent so I think
that's what virgin shows you is that
there's a tremendous value in
anti-correlation and in that I think
that there are a lot of really good
businesses tech businesses that could
benefit by being public and this back in
my opinion is the only way for tech
companies to go public because you're
doing it via a merger the process is
dramatically simplified it's much faster
the capital is flexible meaning you can
raise as much or as little as you want
you can do as much primary or as much
secondary as you want and you have huge
benefits for the employees in that
there's no lock up now try going through
a traditional IPO or even a direct
listing it's a very difficult thing and
I've done the largest direct listing as
well I was the you know Series A
investor in the board member on slack
and so but I can tell you seeing all of
these processes is that slack and
Spotify can do
listing maybe an Airbnb could do a
direct listing although the price is
unclear at this point but most other
companies cannot I think the IPO process
is totally broken and so I think spats
make a ton of sense the other thing that
I would say is specifically around
social capital my dream is for this to
be public and my objective over the long
term is to give individual shareholders
the ability to be beside me and be at
risk with me I can't guarantee that I'll
make great decisions all the time but
what I'll tell you is I'm on a journey
to become the best that I can be and you
know find kind of truth and control and
meaning of my psychology and that
results incremental II I've seen in
better and better decisions and I was
making pretty good decisions when I was
completely dysfunctional and so I kind
of feel like I should be making really
good decisions and so I would love for
it to be public I would love to take a
shot at building the next Berkshire
publicly I would love to have annual
shareholder meetings I would love to you
know have conversations with you
multiplied by you know the hundreds of
thousands of people that listen to you I
would love to have the that connectivity
to people I would love that and I would
love to have the honor of being in
people's portfolio as a way of just
being a smart you know next-generation
thinker so we know where you are today
let's say that that's kind of the not
the finish line but a milestone that
that's in the future
what are the obstacles that you see as
to why not go do that right now that's a
really good I think it's more of my
insecurities than anything else I mean I
think that you know could we do
something sooner rather than later
possibly I think that coming out of this
if we prove that you know our process
was good and that our psychology was
rewarded
I think I'll be ready to be really
honest with you I still battle my ego
all the time and I want to be able to
look you in the eye and tell you that
when I get these belts of inferiority
and superiority I know how to manage
myself because I think that is what like
I said that is what's required to be an
incredibly astute observer of the
present and I think that is the single
biggest requirement to being a great
investor just observing dispassionately
observing what's happening around you
and I still have these you know
follow-ups like I kind of trip up and I
do it to myself so I think when I know
that that is largely behind it'll never
be a hundred percent behind but when I
can like really have a grasp and I have
the mental control to know oh it's
happening to step back
then I'll be ready because then I can
look you in the eye and say you know my
game is a plus it's may not always gonna
work you know I may be on the wrong side
the analysis may be wrong we may not
make the right bets but I am NOT going
to do something that takes away from our
ability to be successful I feel like I'm
pretty close and you know like a process
like this like really it it tests your
mettle yeah I want to finish up ask the
audience for a bunch of questions and I
found some that I just thought were
really interesting or fun MBA you
obviously are a owner of Golden State
Warriors they canceled the season just
thoughts they're kind of how do you see
that playing out and what do you want to
see happen I guess with the league and
with the team I think it's going to be
an incredible boost to America's morale
to get professional sports going
obviously there's a lot of health care
related issues between here and there
both for the players as well as the fans
but it frankly like when it happens I
think it'll just be an enormous boost to
see people playing basket
all to see people playing baseball you
know when the NFL season starts whenever
all of these things happen so I don't
know when it's gonna happen and I don't
know what it's going to take but I think
it's going to be psychologically a very
important it's gonna be hugely
emotionally important thing for America
Quarantine overlaid with no sports is
killing a lot of people in the country
for sure the best tweet on this I saw
was it was very very early into the
quarantine and like the guys tweet was
you know day two of no sports found this
very nice woman sitting beside me turns
out she's my wife absolutely
speaking of quarantine someone asked how
do billionaires quarantine like what's
something that you think that maybe you
do differently than than the average
person or some of the people wouldn't
expect I mean honestly I'm doing
basically the same things as everybody
else I'm cleaning my house I do it every
two days you know mop the floors clean
the toilets make the bed every day what
I've tried to do is create myself a
routine because I think that routine is
very important so you know I've started
to have make my breakfast and then bring
it upstairs and I and I have breakfast
in bed cuz it's like a moment to just
relax and just kind of you know which I
normally wouldn't do but then I get up
and I make the bed I clean the bathrooms
you know make breakfast for the kids I
try to get 10,000 steps a day
under any circumstance I've missed three
days so far in almost a month of
quarantine but so I don't work out
anymore which has been kind of shitty
but you know my whole thing is like I
don't want to I was pushing myself
pretty hard I didn't want to injure
myself I don't want to do something
where I have to go to the hospital in
this moment so I'm just like I'll just
walk do you have a cool quarantine
outfit like a David Sachs posted I saw
he looks like a terminator with his hat
and his gloves and goggles no in fact I
mean like I live in the suburbs of San
Francisco and so Palo Alto area and so
there's not a lot of you know people are
very kind of kind and they respect the
social distancing and they cross the
streets and
no but I don't do anything differently I
mean maybe you know if anything I you
know I I would only drink once a week
now it's like I'll have a glass of wine
every night because I'm like it could be
the end I mean you know you might as
well go in style but I'm not doing
anything differently got it
spaced any interest in being on one of
the early flights now that the your
financially incentivize to see it be
successful well I bought a ticket and
but I'm six hundred and fourth in line
so I don't really get any advantage and
I think that that's right like it's like
I should be waiting in line like
everybody else and you know the other
thing is like I wonder how many people
will wake up and realize like hey listen
I've always wanted to go and become an
astronaut and maybe I was hemming and
hawing I mean I don't think there's
going to be any shortage of people at
this point because I do think that
there's a there's there's a thing that a
lot of people will go through I suspect
when they were quarantined at home which
is just really a ting what's important
mm-hmm you know and and I think a lot of
people come out of this and they'll
double down on relationships they'll end
relationships they'll take the trips
that they've always wanted they'll you
know change behaviors that they didn't
think we're healthy they'll double down
on other behaviors maybe even if they
were unhealthy because they're like
screw it it could go off to hell anyways
but I think that you're going to see a
lot of that Rionda writing and so I
think it generally helps things that are
unique yeah three more for you I think
you and I should probably spend a lot of
time along with many people we engage
with thinking about tech companies
larger companies the Fed finance etc
small businesses in America or getting
decimated
let me just they don't have enough cash
they're being mandated to shut down etc
any thoughts on how small businesses you
know what percentage survive on the
other side of this or kind of what that
segment of the market will look like I
think that I think if you look at the
percentages I could be getting this
wrong so you can tell me if you know
this but I think the the three-year
mortality rate on companies is like 5060
percent on SMBs
sounds actually correct
IIIi think that you basically have to
assume within two or three years it's a
hundred percent turnover so I think it's
really bad I think it's really this and
this is why I think it's it's unfair to
be glib and like focus on the equity
markets above all else or you know think
that the quote-unquote the bottom is in
but all we've done in the stock market
is reprice risk what we have not done is
step two which is trade the news and I
think the news is going to be bad
because unlike 2008 and unlike you know
a few of the recessions before it this
is going to touch everybody you are
going to know people like in your small
circle that are wiped out and I don't
think that was true in 2008 and so we
have a responsibility I think to support
small businesses when they start to
rebuild themselves and I think part of
the way we do it as well is that the
government has to create incentives for
these businesses to onshore a bunch of
things that were offshore I've said this
before
even in my investor letter for 2019 I
think the general trend is towards more
nationalism but this is the best reason
for everybody of all political ilk stew
realize that we do need to nationalize
large parts of our economy it's the only
salvation and in it you can see a
rebirth and a renewal of small business
but otherwise it's a hundred percent
wipe out over three years yeah speaking
of kind of bad situations we are not at
the end so we don't have complete
clarity of the hindsight but there's
been a lot of what I'll just call bad
behavior in the market that led to a lot
of this so whether it's the
over-leveraged of corporations or even
hedge funds at the key talks right at
one point a lot of the debt fueled
buybacks the CEO departure is kind of at
the top all of these things what's your
take at this point in time right so
we're kind of going into this situation
we're not out of it but like how do you
view a lot of that be
right now so I got it I got an email
this morning actually from my prime
broker so hedge funds were at 99 to a
hundredth percentile of their historical
max leverage literally February 20th and
now we're at you know the 20th to 30th
percentile historically so you know we
were probably at 7 or 8 turns of
leverage and now we're probably down to
one and a half to two or three I think
that this next go-around you're going to
have to realize government will have to
realize that in 2008 all they did was
allow financial institutions to pass the
buck they were able to take the leverage
off balance sheet and when you subtract
out debt as a function of GDP for many
years now we have had negative GDP so we
were not growing in the absence of
people issuing debt and most of that
debt unfortunately was not towards R&D
but it was towards things that
superficially propped up stock prices
which really only benefited a handful of
people and I do think we have to
restrain people from being able to do
that in the future I don't think it
makes a lot of sense and I don't think
it adds a lot of value and I think that
it's not that it was obviously
responsible for the coronavirus but I do
think that when you look at how much
devastation we are encountering and when
we do the final tally on the amount of
buyback oh sorry the amount of bailouts
we need the bailouts are directly
correlated to how stupidly run and badly
run these companies were you know why is
it that California is legally mandated
and you'll say oh because it's a
nonprofit but legally mandated to have a
rainy day fund but a company isn't and
then the company is the first one to
knock on the door of the government and
we're just waiting for the next shoe to
drop or California Mississippi Alabama
Louisiana to all do the same thing and I
would much rather see the money go to
the states and the cities in an in an
fair even
then the money go to a private company I
think that those private companies
should be wiped out the equity should be
wiped out and they should need to
restart it's one thing I'm a hundred
percent in alignment with you on this
but the part that I don't understand is
how do you continue to benefit from the
elements of capitalism if you take out
the risk moving forward it everyone
knows I can quote unquote take this like
fake risk and if anything goes wrong I
can just run to the government and get a
bailout you changed the dynamic of what
happens and I actually think you
incentivize even more bad behavior right
it's almost like there was bad behavior
and then there was no punishment for it
and therefore you just encouraged that
to continue you know when we get out of
this thing well I it depends on what you
view capitalism as I think if you view
capitalism as a game of risk I think
you're right I've always viewed
capitalism as money becomes a fulcrum
instrument for change what do you want
to see in the world okay
money is your lubricant you decide and
the person with more money or the person
who's willing to put more money into
something and who can be more clever
basically has the opportunity to win so
I I think it's a game that puts
ingenuity and money at the forefront
that's what to me that's what capitalism
is and so when companies are doing
things that are fundamentally not
advancing that forward they should
disqualify themselves from them being
able to run to the government so it
would be a different thing entirely if
all the airlines had invested let's just
say 96% of free cash flow dollars on
supersonic flight failed and then came
to the government and said look I took a
big bet on the future to help advance
humanity it didn't work and I need a
bailout I would be the first one to say
okay but when 96% of free cash flow
dollars go back to buying back shares
and then you basically claim the same
thing I think you should be punished and
punished financially so you know you you
you took the money that you had you
refused it you refused to multiply it by
a good smart bet on the future and I
think that there should be consequences
for that
yeah I don't disagree with you at all
last question for you
been incredible kind with your time here
if you were the president over the next
six months
what's your playbook so president Shamus
got full control can do whatever was it
within the presidential powers what's
your playbook to kind of weather the
storm and get us out of this
I would first stand up every single
voting site that we would use in the
November election
and I would schedule every single man
woman and child to come through all of
those testing facilities and I would
basically deploy a rapid test to figure
out whether they had coronavirus in that
moment okay and families could come you
know 10 minutes apart so that you could
get back into your car and go etc etc in
step number one if you didn't have
Corona so you weren't shedding the RNA
in that moment you go to a second and
you get administered a finger prick
and you get tested for the antibodies
and within 15 or 20 minutes and you're
held in an isolation
you know booth area where you you know
you're on Instagram and when you're done
you're given a wristband and that
wristband basically says one of three
things well if you had tested positive
you get a red band you go home and you
isolate if you test negative and you
have the antibodies you get a green one
and if you test negative and you how
don't have the antibodies maybe you get
a blue one green and blue are allowed to
go back to work right away red self
isolates you contact trace etcetera etc
that's sort of the frontline of getting
the economy back to work and you have
some combination of the National Guard
and sort of like a whole infrastructure
then separately I think you introduced a
massive massive massive infrastructure
bill that starts to drive the
refactoring
of the supply chain back in
to the United States and part of that is
incentives and part of that is
government spending and it has to cut
across many categories from you know
semiconductors in silicon all the way to
clean energy to actual physical
infrastructure like you know bridges and
and tunnels and roads and in that what I
think you're mandating is a certain
percentage of things to be made
domestically in the United States and
you start to get people back to work so
the short term path I think is to kind
of baseline the disease and get the
people who are allowed to be working
back into a green zone of every city
every town where people with these green
and blue bands are allowed inside and
the red banded people have to stay and
quarantine themselves so that we can
start to restart this economy and then
longer-term is an infrastructure build
that basically resets incentives towards
resiliency towards inefficiency away
from efficiency I think that's a pretty
solid plan I'm shot I'm actually shocked
that some of this hasn't been instituted
already the lack of testing just blows
my mind I mean the stats I saw on
Saturday 895 thousand people I think
I've been tested at a 330 million in the
United States I think the other
reckoning that we have to do maybe just
to finish on this is that we've
politicized things that should never
have been politicized health should not
be politicized you know the problem is
that starting with Obamacare health
became something that was about the
Democrats versus the Republicans and you
can see how that's sort of like you know
flowed into things like the FDA and the
CDC and history will tell what they
could have done better history will tell
what the w-h-o should have done
differently
but I think what we can see is that
there are many points along the
evolution of this disease where logic
and open-mindedness and iteration ran
into bureaucracy and bureaucracy one and
I think that's probably the most
generous way of describing it and we
need to figure out
where there are almost constitutional
level provisions you know you have the
right to bear arms great what about the
right to basically not you know not die
in a preventable scenario what does that
mean for how these organizations should
run you know we at a very basic level
have told the healthcare infrastructure
that we must do no harm and I think it's
time to say look with 8 billion people
in the world and a 90 trillion dollar
economy that supports those eight eight
eight billion people do no harm doesn't
work anymore it doesn't scale we need to
do our best and there's a lot of rules
that could change in a scenario where
you embrace do your best and I think
that that that has to happen but the
failures of the political infrastructure
and the healthcare infrastructure to use
bureaucracy as the thing that that
drives decision making I think is also
the a domino that has to fall after this
and we need to revisit because it's a
you know we've we've done a lot of
unnecessary damage to ourselves and some
of this some of these self-inflicted
injuries we should figure out how to
prevent for the next time because it's
gonna come again yeah I think we're
living in incredibly uncertain in
chaotic times and you know one just
thank you for your time today but uh too
is uh think I speak for a lot of people
in that we'd love to see you go public
and kind of be along for the journey so
you're doing an incredible job and I
just appreciate you uh
kind of going out there and sticking
your neck out there frankly because a
lot of people who they they're gonna all
be the armchair quarterbacks right okay
two three years from now like I said I
told you that we should have done X or Y
but right now they're they're kind of
quiet so we'll see how it plays out well
I really appreciate the fact that you
had me on and I just want to say that I
think you've been a really good person
in being out there in this moment the
reality is like in moments like this you
need people to be coalescing opinions
and I think that you've done that that's
a really important service because it
allows people to get to ground truth so
I just want to say thank you for doing
that
thanks for including me
no problem at all all right sir well
thank you a teacher
all the best talk to you soon right bye